Speaker 1: All right. This is
not a Saturday Night Live skit.
This is not a joke. They are now blaming
doors for the shooting in Duvall de Texas.
This is truly beyond parody. We're going
to look at a video here of Ted Cruz.
Ted Cruz is not the only one talking about this.
You see here a little screenshot from Texas
Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick. Sorry, I'm having
trouble getting it on the screen. Here it is.
Too many entrances and exits on campuses. Okay,
so let's look. Here is Ted Cruz when he was
in Nevada yesterday, came across this new idea.
Let's not talk about guns. Let's talk about doors.
Speaker 4: You want to talk about how we
could have prevented the horror that played
out across the street? Look, the killer, this.
Speaker 1: Is a principled and defiant Ted Cruz
bravely coming out against.
Speaker 4: Doors, entered here
the same way the killer entered Santa Fe
through a back door, an unlocked back door.
I sat down at roundtables with the families from
Santa Fe. We talked about what we need to do to
harden schools, including he's.
Speaker 1: Furious at doors,
guys. He's furious at doors.
Speaker 4: Not having unlocked
back doors, including not having unlocked
doors to the classroom, having one
door that goes in and out of the school, having
armed police officers at that one door doing okay.
Speaker 1: Then he went on Fox News. This started
to get some traction. So then he went on Fox News
and did the exact same routine about doors.
Speaker 4: Schools safer. And one of the things
that everyone agreed is don't have all of these
unlocked back doors, have one door into and out of
the school and have that one door. Armed police
officers at that door, if that had happened,
if those federal grants had gone to this
school, when that psychopath arrived, the
armed police officers could have taken him out.
Speaker 1: The remember, the armed police officers
were there and they did confront the suspect. And
then he went in for 40 to 60 Minutes to rampage in
the classroom. Think about the absurdity of these
people. There's too many doors. It's not too many
guns. There's just too many doors. Now, let's talk
about doors. Okay. At the high school I went to.
Now, during school hours, all of the doors are
locked going in. You still have the push bar so
you can get out. But the only door that's unlocked
going in is the one that leads directly into the
front office where people have to check in. Fine.
I mean, okay, do that. That's fine. But remember,
an armed officer did confront the shooter outside
of the school and then the shooter went in. And
then we're learning that he was in there 40 to
60 minutes after the confrontation. What the hell
is going on here? What how is doors the issue?
Secondly, children never go outside for recess.
When you when the other concern from security
experts about the one door thing is if everybody
knows the one door that's being used, then the
shooter can just hang around right at that door.
There are fire code issues as well. And, you know,
when when Ted Cruz says we got a psychopath here
and the doors is what we need to do. Well, why
wouldn't the psychopath target the kids backed up
in the line to get in the one door that will let
them through. So locking doors, having a police
officer at the school, bulletproof windows, these
are reactions, but they're not solutions. Okay.
And by the way, imagine that you do this at
schools. Do you do it at the grocery store
because the buffalo shooting was at the grocery
store? Well, what if it's the parking lot to the
grocery store? Well, I guess you put in fencing
around the parking lot and go through TSA style
security to even get into the parking lot for the
for the super guys churches now. Okay. You've got
to solve the issue of people trying to do the
shootings. The doors are not going to be the
solution. And Ted Cruz was actually confronted by
a Sky News journalist of all people. We're going
to look at that a little bit later after we speak
to Jonathan Height. Quick break. Back after this.